cooking is about being adventurous and
having the confidence to go off piste
and being a little bit more daring so
when you start combining peanuts chili
flakes and this amazing fish red mullet
trust me you in for an amazing treat
we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce first off good chili
off with the top in half and those seeds
inside are very powerful incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic 2 cloves of
garlic slice the garlic nice and thin so
it helps the puree the chilies in the
pesto more garlic in such a salt and it
will touch off sugar in and then start
grinding push down first the salt and
the sugar really helps the puree the
chili and the garlic fish sauce always a
base to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
and a touch of rice wine vinegar fish
sauce gives it the saltiness the vinegar
gives it a nice acidic wake up 3
tablespoons of olive oil nice mix that
up beautiful look at the colors
incredible now spring onions
I want the texture and the crunch spring
onions in the coriander slice it once in
fresh lime and that goes brilliantly
with a red mullet just really wakes up
the chili the garlic and reminds the
sauce that was serving with fish now
taste
hmm wow it's delicious look at that
beautiful the longer that chili sauce
sits there the better it gets
now the peanuts and chili that's gonna
coat the top the red mullet peanuts in
salt in it helps the really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dry chili
flakes
create a nice sort of warm heat I'm
using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit the coriander mix the
kinder in to the peanuts and lo I like
them quite textured I don't want to
small as a powder otherwise they'll burn
but crush lightly to coat the fish with
the chili and peanut seasoning in a
separate bowl beat two eggs along with a
splash of fish sauce take your Philip
lay in your red mullet dip it in shake
up your peanuts and then end and make
sure you push that down cover that red
mullet Oh beautiful
now make sure that pan is really nice
and piping hot if you put the fish in
the pans cold all those wonderful
peanuts and chili doesn't slide off the
fish so we need to sear it in and get it
nice and crisp in and lay away from me
beautiful
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot get your ball and just place
another teaspoon of olive oil around the
outside so it starts to heat up as it
hits the center and it really helps to
say so much more in control and turn
nice and gently we want that nice sort
of toasted sauteed crispness which it
adds a really lovely flavor tilt the pan
and just base the top of the red mullet
without really nice quite clean hot
olive oil you've got that really nice
roasted crunch and it goes brilliantly
without soft sweetness of that fish
inside guess off and just leave them
sitting in there and finish with lime
and just go over each one now take them
out in the source touch on the bottom in
the turn of each fish now to round that
off serve in some fragrant rice study
broccoli amazing and there you have a
delicious peanut encrusted red mullet
with a wonderful sweet chili sauce
cooking with chilies isn't all about
blow your head off heat this dish uses
the exciting taste of a chili where has
a deliciously elegant and subtle flavor
and turn nice and gently what's nice
going with the grain it's almost like
slicing through butter